[Musica]
[Applauso]
avete mai avuto sensi di colpa guardando
i bidoni pieni di imballaggi di casa
vostra a me capita praticamente sempre
in particolare ricordo un momento nel
2016 quando era una studentessa di
design a Bolzano e guardavo questo
barattolino di dado da brodo e pensavo
che se accidentalmente fosse finito in
mare avesse causato la morte di qualche
Creatura marina sarebbe stata colpa mia
l'ho sentita questo senso di sconforto
a me questa sensazione non solo ha
portato quasi all'accumulo patologico ma
anche la domanda centrale della mia tesi
di laurea triennale ovvero possiamo
sviluppare degli imballaggi che invece
che inquinare la terra la nutro nella
beneficia No una compagna di corso mi ha
consigliato il libro Good design di
Bruno Munari del 1963 in cui si parla
dell'arancia con me un prodotto perfetto
il succo è contenuto in piccole capsule
che sono a loro volta contenuti spicchi
arrangiate intorno a un asse creando una
specie di sfera questa sfera è contenuta
in una buccia che è imbottita
all'interno e esternamente è sia
traspirante che resistente all'acqua
tutti i materiali nell'arancia sono
fatti della stessa natura e quindi ho
avuto un'intuizione in ogni regione ci
sono tonnellate tonnellate di scarti a
base di bucce di frutta e verdura che
vengono immediatamente trasformati in
fertilizzante e quindi tutte le sostanze
ancora preziose che contengono vanno
completamente sprecate
mi sono quindi chiesta ci sarà un modo
per trasformare le bucce in nuove
imballaggi ed è così che iniziata una
ricerca che mi ha portato una delle mie
più grandi ossessioni il microcosmo quel
Vasto mondo di organismi che possono
essere solo visti attraverso un
microscopio Ma che cavolo c'entrano i
microrganismi in un discorso sul
Packaging Centrone come perché intanto
che noi siamo qui e cerchiamo di gestire
i nostri sistemi rigidi e non
sostenibili loro continuano ad adattarsi
a condizioni avverse in primis perché
basano le loro relazioni sulla
collaborazione e in seconda Perché tutte
le sostanze che producono sono utili ad
altri Non esiste il concetto di rifiuto
come designer ho un interesse viscerale
nella ricerca nello sviluppo di
soluzioni che non solo possono
migliorare la vita delle persone ma
anche delle altre specie questo quindi
mi porta a collaborare con altre
discipline per esempio con microbiologi
tecnologia alimentari antropologi e da
grazie a questa sinergia che riusciamo a
sviluppare delle soluzioni che possono
essere ideali per dei contesti specifici
nella nicchia emergente del Bio design i
designer superano la logica della
produzione di massa dei materiali
prestabiliti ma collaborano con i
microrganismi per sviluppare nuovi
sistemi e materiali più sostenibili
nel 2016 quando cercavo di capire come
trasformare le bucce e nuove imballaggi
ho scoperto dell'esistenza di un gruppo
questo di microrganismi più
specificatamente un consorzio che si
chiama Scoby coltura simbiotica di
batteri e lieviti Anche detta madre
acetica è famosa Perché si usa per
produrre la con buccia che è una bevanda
a base di te fermentato che risale
addirittura a più di duemila anni fa il
Manciuria Ma che oggigiorno è sempre più
popolare anche in Europa
il processo per produrre la scopi è
abbastanza semplice serve un contenitore
che va riempito di liquido nutritivo poi
la scopi viene immersa nel contenitore e
parte un processo di fermentazione alla
fine del quale una nuova scopi cresce
sul pelo del liquido e assume questo
aspetto quando questa specie di gelatina
è abbastanza spessa si può prendere
porre su una superficie e aspettare che
si secchi quello che andiamo a ottenere
è uno strato semitrasparente che sembra
unire le qualità di cartapelle e
plastica e grazie a dei nostri colleghi
tecnologi alimentari abbiamo scoperto
che è più o meno stabile due anni prima
di decomporsi
è particolarmente resistente questa
residenza
è data dalla presenza di microfibre che
vengono anche chiamate Cellulosa
batterica sappiamo che la cellulosa è
una sostanza molto importante al giorno
d'oggi perché viene impiegata non solo
per produrre fibre che possono essere
tessili Ma addirittura anche materiali
come la carta quindi è molto importante
averla
abbiamo anche scoperto grazie ad
articoli scientifici che la scopi Non
può essere prodotta solamente con il tè
zuccherato ma anche con gli zuccheri
naturalmente presenti nelle biomasse di
frutta e verdura quindi la scopi offre
una opportunità di economia circolare
Quindi quello che ho fatto nel 2016 è
stato comprare delle vasche e anche
ottenere delle dei campioni di biomasse
locali e ho iniziato a fermentarle in
una teglia della facoltà di arte design
Per la gioia delle mie compagnette
esiste che esistono dovute assorbire
l'odore
una delle prime domande che mi sono
posta è Ma come si fa a lavorare con i
microrganismi e la risposta è più o meno
come con le persone quindi bisogna
imparare a conoscerle e capire che
preferenze hanno in Che ambiente si
sentono meglio che cosa le rende più
produttive che cosa le piace
e questo si riesce a capire attraverso i
sensi come ho fatto la vista per
comprendere se la crescita sta andando
bene e poi anche essenziale ovviamente
collaborare con degli scienziati che
possono aiutare a
determinare Quali sono le condizioni di
crescita ideali grazie a questa
conoscenza sono riuscita a capire come
creare diversi strati di diversi
spessori e sfumature utilizzando liquidi
differenti e poi per tornare alla mia
domanda iniziale mi sono chiesta Quali
tipi di imballaggi potrebbero essere
ideali in un contesto su tirolese e
quindi ho sviluppato dei prodotti più
unici per prodotti locali per esempio
degli Snack a base di mela secca Oppure
delle caramelle degli infuso a base di
erbe alpine e poi pensando allo Street
Food o anche sviluppato delle proposte
per esempio di vassoi e coppette gelato
usa e getta c'è un interesse
interessantissima connessione e
relazione con il locale perché se in
sudtterò lo possiamo usare attualmente
per esempio le biomasse di mela in
Sicilia potremmo utilizzare quelli di
agrumi rendendo ogni località intorno al
mondo potenzialmente molto più
resiliente almeno per produrre una parte
dei propri imballaggi
questa tesi Grazie ai miei mentori è
germogliata in un progetto
interdisciplinare e chiamato innocell
che è stato condotto ad esemption Lab
della facoltà di design e dalla
piattaforma di tecnologia elementare
della facoltà di scienze e tecnologie
della libero università di Bolzano ed è
stato finanziato dalla provincia
autonoma
quindi in circa tre anni ci siamo
focalizzati su due aspetti principali
produzione e ulteriore applicazione
Innanzitutto ci siamo resi conto che
produrre tanta scopi è problematico È
complicato perché serve tanta superficie
quindi servono tante vasche e stare
Monitorare le tutte estremamente
laborioso
Tuttavia grazie alla ricerca abbiamo
scoperto che esiste un brevetto scaduto
che parla di un principio di rotazione
Questo vuol dire che la scopi non cresce
più sul pelo del liquido ma si aggrappa
a entrambe le facce di dischi che
continuamente ruotano dentro il liquido
nutritivo quindi questo cosa vuol dire
vuol dire in primis che aumenta
tantissimo l'ossigenazione e quindi alla
scopi piace da morire e quindi è
possibile creare molta più massa in un
volume molto più limitato abbiamo quindi
cominciato a sviluppare un'unità da 16
litri per fare tutti i nostri test per
poi passare una versione finale da 25
devo ammettere che questa è stata la
parte più difficile di tutto il progetto
perché io non ho competenze in
ingegneria raccordi sistemi idraulici
abbiamo dovuto fare dozzine diterazioni
cambiare pezzi rotti capire quali
componenti fossero ideali anche dover
gestire delle contaminazioni che sono
successe durante i cicli Ma alla fine
soprattutto grazie agli altri membri del
team di design e a consulenti esterni
siamo riusciti ad arrivare a una
versione finale da 25 litri che vedete
in funzione qui sopra che permette di
avere alla fine di un ciclo tra i 12 e
15 kg di scovi e quest'unità è circa
lungo un metro per 30 cm abbiamo pensato
poi di condividere questa conoscenza che
abbiamo generato mettendo le istruzioni
per produrre questa unità che noi
chiamiamo il bioreattore online con una
licenza Creative commons in modo da
permettere a più persone intorno al
mondo di produrre scopi in maniera più
efficiente
il bioratore è servito anche all'interno
del progetto innocell per capire quali
materiali potrebbe essere possibile
ottenere oltre ai fogli e quindi sono
stata letteralmente mesi con le mani in
pasta tra laboratori scientifici cucine
fablab e le officine della facoltà di
design
ho provato una serie di processi e
protocolli per capire cosa fosse
possibile ottenere alla fine di questa
fase molto sperimentale sono riuscita ad
arrivare a dei prototipi di materiali e
quindi la scopi è diventata polvere
granulato fogli con diverse texture ed
effetti estetici ma in particolare sono
davvero fiera di una ricetta che mi ha
chiesto più di 60 iterazioni e permette
di ottenere una schiuma solida ovvero un
materiale che è simile alla consistenza
degli snack soffiati ci siamo quindi
chiesti cosa è possibile creare con un
materiale che può essere molto
voluminoso e allo stesso tempo per
leggero e abbiamo pensato a tutti quei
blocchi a quei cuscinetti protettivi che
proteggono i prodotti nuovi che
acquistiamo e spesso sono all'interno di
scatoloni questi blocchi tendenzialmente
sono fatti di polistirolo che è un
materiale sintetico tra i più inquinanti
che abbiamo e abbiamo pensato che di
fatto sarebbe ideale avere invece
un'alternativa che non solo è
compostabile ma potrebbe essere prodotta
localmente e permetterci anche di
fertilizzare Addirittura il nostro
giardino e quindi per dimostrare ciò
abbiamo sviluppato dei modelli di
packaging mono materiale per esempio per
impacchettare smartphone cuffie
contenitori multiuso e poi queste famose
Chips per imballaggi
fino a qui Vi ho parlato solamente di
packaging Tuttavia Abbiamo anche mandato
dei campioni di scopi cresciuta dalle
biomasse di mela ad analizzare da
esperti microbiologi del micro-for Food
Lab che ci hanno
fornito dei dati preliminari Ma che ci
hanno suggerito una possibilità che ha
radicalmente ampliato la nostra visione
ovvero che la scopi ha un potenziale
prebiotico e questo cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che non solo si può mangiare Ma che
contiene antiossidanti e quindi potrebbe
potenzialmente nutrire i batteri buoni
che abbiamo nell'intestino e come dicono
i recenti studi sul microbioma è molto
importante prenderci cura di loro per
supportare la nostra salute in senso
olistico
subentra Tuttavia un problema e chi si
fa la Conduci a casa lo sa benissimo
ovvero che la scopi Ha una consistenza
simile alle seppie e un sapore simile
all'aceto
quindi qui subentra di nuovo torna in
gioco Il design che non sono incontrato
l'ingegneria Le Scienze dei materiali la
microbiologia ma è arrivata anche al
cibo e quindi alla fine del progetto
innocell abbiamo proposto due concetti
alimentari quindi in questo caso un
granulato soffiato che si può aggiungere
ai cereali oppure uno snack simile alle
gallette Ma siccome questo potenziale
era estremamente interessante per me ho
deciso di sviluppare ulteriormente anche
nella mia tesi di laurea magistrale in
eco Social design ho quindi collaborato
con il gruppo di fermentazione e
distillazione del centro
centro di sperimentazione laimburg con
cui abbiamo effettivamente
confermato questo potenziale prebiotico
di scovi cresciuta da 4 diverse biomasse
che si trovano a livello locale quindi
mela rape rosse lampone e uva e poi ho
collaborato con uno chef Stellato con
cui abbiamo sviluppato dei concetti
alimentari per facilitare un ipotetica
l'integrazione della scopi
nell'alimentazione quotidiana e infatti
essenziale che quando si propone un
ingrediente o un cibo innovativo sia
intuitivo comprendere Come poter
utilizzare e come preparare questa nuova
pietanza e questi aspetti si possono
progettare attraverso la semiotica o che
quando è applicata al design del
prodotto si intende come la capacità di
un prodotto di comunicare significati al
consumatore e quindi ho deciso di
mettere in gioco tutte le competenze e
tutta la conoscenza che ho preso dallo
sviluppo dei materiali per enfatizzare
le proprietà nutrizionali della scopi e
quindi ho pensato cosa potrebbe
invogliare persone in Europa del sud e
soprattutto anche in Italia che è uno
dei luoghi a livello gastronomico più
conservatori che esistono appunto
integrare la scopi nella propria
quotidianità
ho quindi pensato a dei concetti per
esempio di pasta che sfruttando la
capacità di assorbenza della scopi
potrebbe essere preparata immergendola
direttamente nel sugo o nel brodo oppure
a delle chips ricche di Fibra oppure un
budello per salsicce vegetali che
sfrutta la capacità della scopi di
essere una barriera per l'ossigeno
poi ho anche pensato a come siamo
abituati a vedere gli integratori nella
nostra quotidianità ed è spesso sotto
forma di polveri capsule e pillole e ho
pensato che di fatto la scopi offre
l'opportunità di aggiungere consistenza
estetica e anche valori nutrizionali i
nostri piatti e quindi ho pensato a un
condimento a base di sfere gelatinose
che potrebbe aggiungere per esempio a
insalato piatti freddi ha delle capsule
solubile con cui potremmo colorare i
nostri impasti le nostre bevande delle
caramelle gelatinose con appunto un
aggiunta nutrizionale oppure addirittura
dei ghiaccioli con anche diverse
proprietà nutrizionali
devo dire che queste proposte sono
ancora in fase sperimentale io ne
assaggiate alcune posso dirvi che c'è
potenziale ma non sono ancora
esattamente buone da mangiare per questo
serve ulteriore ricerca
e ulteriori collaborazioni
in questi anni Abbiamo dimostrato
attraverso il design che i microrganismi
sono degli ottimi alleati per affrontare
le sfide del presente
approcci di biodesign stanno fiorendo
intorno al mondo e soprattutto anche in
Europa abbiamo ricercatori a Bolzano a
Milano a Lecce in nei Paesi Bassi a
delft nel Regno Unito a Londra anche in
Germania Francoforte e a Berlino dove
sono attualmente affiliata al gruppo di
ricerca meteosov Activity della
community University in cui sto
collaborando con microbiologi
antropologi per investigare le relazioni
tra Umani piante e microrganismi per
scoprire nuove alleanze che possono
aumentare la resilienza alla
sostenibilità locale e da lì che a breve
comincerò il mio dottorato di ricerca
lavorare con i microrganismi mi ha
radicalmente cambiata a espanso la mia
visione
affinato il tipo di futuro che voglio
vedere e mi ha portato una profonda
riconnessione con me stessa
Tuttavia tutta la ricerca che avete
visto è più realistica Quindi la
prossima volta che vedrete tonnellate di
scarti alimentari e bidoni pieni di
imballaggi i sensi di colpa resteranno
ma di tutto ciò che ho detto oggi ciò
che dovete ricordarvi è che la
resilienza era sopravvivenza si basano
sulla collaborazione e sulle relazioni
di cura
Infatti se non fosse stato per tutte
queste persone il loro supporto loro
collaborazione il loro lavoro Tutto ciò
che avete visto non sarebbe mai stato
possibile Grazie
[Applauso]